i'm marley kerr
a sophomore studying religion and
politics
and it's my honor to introduce tonight's
speaker
mr robert r riley is the director of the
westminster institute
he was educated at georgetown university
the national chenchi university in
taiwan and the claremont graduate school
a former u.s army tank platoon leader
and former president
of the intercollegiate studies institute
mr riley served as a special assistant
to president reagan
and later as director of the voice of
america
he worked in the george w bush
administration
as senior advisor for information
strategy under the secretary of defense
and he participated in operation iraqi
freedom
as senior adviser to the iraqi ministry
of information
he was taught at the national defense
university
and recently served as director of voice
of america
for a second time he is the author of
the closing of the muslim mind
how intellectual suicide created the
modern islamic crisis
and america on trial a defense of the
founding
please join me in welcoming tonight's
speaker mr robert r riley
thank you very much marley for that
wonderful introduction
um well i want to thank
doug jeffrey and matt bell
kim ellison for all she did and sorry
ellsworth and all
of the work she did on the arrangements
and most of all of course i want to
thank
larry yarn
my former classmate at claremont
graduate university
he stipulated that my appearance here
was only on condition that i not
tell any stories from
graduate school when this kid from
arkansas
arrived with well a little hay in his
hair
so i'll keep that promise larry wherever
you are
by the way i was very pleased that we
merely mentioned the book america on
trial
a defense of the founding
preface by larry yarn
larry told me at dinner how irritated he
was that some people have
come up to him and said
you know bob riley and he says
no bob riley knows me
[Laughter]
so well here we go i'm afraid this is a
a very serious subject that requires
some ponderous thought and i was trying
on the flight up
here today from washington d.c
to try to cut out some things but if i
go for too long
and cut into the q a period matt has
promised that he'll get the hook
and keep me quiet so our topic is faith
reason and education i will concentrate
on the relationship between faith and
reason
which one would need a very good
education to explore and
to understand properly the very
differentiation
of faith and reason is something of a
relatively recent provenance
and is uniquely western ancient tribal
man
would not have understood the
distinction
it was born of the contact between greek
philosophy
and christianity only that
encounter or collision if you will
generated the concepts and faith and
reason as two distinct
realms tertullian famously asked what
has athens
to do with jerusalem
this question has reverberated down the
centuries
nearer to our own time the great
political philosopher leo
strauss said that these two cities
the one representing philosophy and the
other divine revelation
each made their own comprehensive claim
to understanding what completes man
according to what is highest in him
he suggested that these claims are
antithetical to each other
but that neither can be disproven
moreover he said that the unresolved
tension between these two cities was
fructifying it is what animated western
civilization
and made its great achievements possible
eric vogelen
thought that the unresolved tension was
not between these two cities
but between imminence and transcendence
and that reason was just as much a form
of revelation
as revelation itself these are two
possible answers to tertalian's question
there's not sufficient time to discuss
them in relation to
islam or judaism but let's consider
these questions in regard to
christianity
are faith and reason headed forever
for a head-on collision with each other
or are they actually in separate but
parallel lanes headed in the same
direction toward a final destination and
the highest truth
do they have nothing to say to each
other or can
each be understood better in light of
the other
to those who say faith has nothing to do
with reason
ignore what faith itself says of reason
and is not reason inelectably drawn to
judge
whether the content of faith itself is
reasonable
does it have the competence to do that
these are the issues i want to touch
upon this evening
there's been a lot of ink and some blood
spilled over these questions
henry cardinal manning in the 19th
century
said quote all human conflict is
ultimately theological
unquote does this mean that people with
different theologies must kill each
other
for extended periods of history the
answer was yes
my god will defeat your god on the field
of battle
it was often thought that no society or
political order could cohere
unless it was religiously homogeneous
this is sometimes referred to as the
theological political problem
that it need not be so has been
demonstrated by the achievement of the
united states
in any case the answers to these
questions will affect the conduct of our
lives
because they concern the nature of
reality
our ways of knowing it and the truth of
things including the purpose of our
lives
of course the answers will depend on the
content of what reason reveals and on
what revelation discloses
i will touch upon the respective
contributions of these cities
and suggest in what way they illuminate
each other
i'll also try to sketch out the
consequences of the position that they
are
completely bifurcated and antagonistic
how was the authority of reason
established in the first place
upon what grounds did athens claim
that the world is intelligible to our
reason
what makes it apprehensible
how could greek philosophy claim the
aptitude to know the answers to these
things
from where did its confidence come that
reason
is a better guide to reality than say
the divination of
animal entrails by the high priest
some claim it was heraclitus who first
grasped
that the universe is an intelligible
whole
and that therefore man is able to
apprehend its order
how can man do this and in what terms
can it be articulated
heraclitus said the universe is
intelligible
because it is ruled by and is the
product
of thought or wisdom
giving it an intrinsic rationality
as far as we know heraclitus and
parmenides
were the first to use the word logos
to name this wisdom logos means reason
or word in greek
heraclitus meant that all things are
animated by a rational principle
he stated that quote all things come to
pass
in accordance with this logos
unquote if this is true then reasons
inquiry into the nature of reality
becomes
possible the very idea of nature
becomes possible heraclitus said quote
it is the highest virtue
and true wisdom in speaking and acting
to obey nature that is the common logos
therefore all human laws are nourished
by this
original divine law unquote
it is lagos that makes the world
intelligible to the endeavor of
philosophy
and it is why laws in turn must be
reasonable
as socrates later said quote the world
is the product of a mind
which sets everything in order and
produces each individual thing
in the way that is best for it unquote
we can have thoughts about
things that are the product of thought
we can also have thoughts about the
thinker
leading aristotle to describe god as
thought thinking itself
the maker is reflected in the things he
made
since they are not made accidentally
but according to lagos
through reason said socrates man can
know
what is now aristotle said that
what is operates according to the laws
of nature
he taught that the essence or nature of
a thing
is what makes it what it is and why it
is not and
cannot be something else
in the politics he said that the nature
of things
consist in their end or consummation
i'm quoting from him now for what each
thing is when its growth is completed we
call the nature of that thing
whether it be a man or a horse or a
family unquote
for example an acorn develops into
an oak tree there is no point along its
trajectory of growth that it will turn
into something other than an
oak that is because it has the nature of
an oak tree and not of anything else
it is inwardly directed to be an oak
tree
hence by nature a natural law aristotle
meant the principle of development
which makes any living thing what it is
and given the proper conditions what it
will become when it reaches its
perfection or fulfillment for aristotle
quote
nature ever seeks an end unquote
he declared quote nature does nothing
without purpose or uselessly
unquote this end state
is its telos the reason for which it is
the telos of the acorn is a fully mature
oak tree
philosopher robert sokolovsky said quote
the end of a thing
is its perfection the nature
is what is perfected the nature and end
of the thing
are normative for that thing
the end in particular is how the thing
should be
unquote the natural law for each thing
is what allows us to speak
of what it ought to be
this means that what is good for a thing
are those things or actions that
assisted in reaching its perfection
for example the right kind of soil and
moisture
are good for the acorn in reaching its
perfection as an oak tree
likewise those things that inhibit or
prevent
something from reaching its end are bad
for it
as drought or poisoned soil would be bad
for an acorn
in each case aristotle would refer to
the good things
for the growth of the oak tree as
natural
to it and the bad things for its growth
as unnatural to it what is good or
natural for something is therefore
intrinsic to that thing
internal to an inseparable from it
it is not imposed from the outside nor
can it be altered
well what is the standard we should use
to measure things regarding man's nature
and end
and how do we discern what is in court
in accord with it or against it
aristotle states open quotes in order to
find what is
natural we must look among those things
which according to nature
are in a sound condition not among those
that are
corrupt unquote
if you want to know what a healthy man
is you don't look at a sick man you look
at a healthy man in politics he says
quote
thus the human being to be studied is
the one whose state is best
best both in body and soul in him this
is clear unquote
thus because we know what a human being
is
in the fullest we can understand what a
privation is
including for each and every part of man
for example let's say for the sake of
argument the 2020 vision is the best for
the eye
and blindness is the worst with 20 20
vision the eye has reached its complete
actuality it is perfect as an eye
it possesses no potential to see better
than it does
in each case of imperfection there's
something missing
that ought to be there for instance the
limb
ought to be able to move in its full
strength the ear ought to be able to
hear in the eye to see
the further a thing is from its
perfection the more defective
or corrupt is aristotle used the term
uh the more corrupt it is just as
blindness is the first furthest defect
of an eye
a privation of the good cannot
itself be good
in fact as saint augustine said evil is
a privation of the good
now man alone has the ability to choose
between
those acts or things which are conducive
to his
end and those which are not
animals plants or rocks cannot do this
only man can act in defiance of his
nature
which is what defines evil for him
since man freely chooses his behavior
he is the only one for whom natural law
is moral this is why aristotle said
quote the moral activities
are human par excellence unquote
therefore references to natural law in
regard to man mean not so much the
physical laws or instinct to which he's
subject
like the lower orders of being but the
moral law
which applies exclusively to him
man does not get to fabricate his end or
telos
human nature is a given its meaning is
not
located in man's will or desires
but in pre-existing reality
in what is consequently while man can
know what is good or evil
according to his nature he does not have
the prerogative
to determine what is good or evil
oughtness is already in the given nature
of things
excuse me
therefore man is morally obliged to
choose the good that will bring about
what ought to be
otherwise he will become less than fully
human
and what he ought not to be perhaps
something worse than a beast is
aristotle warned
if every human must be if everything
human must be measured
against it what is man's telos
aristotle answered quote happiness is
the highest good
being a realization and perfect practice
of virtue
unquote having established the primacy
of reason
as the highest human faculty
aristotle asked in what way it served
man's end
he answered that the highest exercise of
man's reason is contemplation of the
highest good
which is divine
he wrote quote contemplation
is the highest form of activity since
the intellect is the highest
thing in us and the objects it
apprehends are the highest things that
can be known
unquote he said that quote the activity
of god
which surpasses all others in
blessedness
must be contemplative and of human
activities therefore
that which is most akin to this
must be most of the nature of happiness
unquote if man is by nature in relation
to a divine good it must mean
that he has within himself some means of
coming to know it
with his finite mind man can somehow
apprehend at least in part the infinite
though he is not divine man must strive
to be god-like
through the exercise of his reason
aristotle counseled that quote
we must not follow those who advise us
being men
to think of human things and being
mortal
of mortal things but must
so far as we can make ourselves
immortal and strain
every nerve to live in accordance with
the best thing
in us for even if it be small in bulk
much more does it empower and worth
surpass
everything unquote
we see in aristotle's account
and adam bration of thomas aquinas's
definition of the final and perfect
happiness
as quote nothing else than the vision of
the divine essence
unquote thus it was
thanks to greek philosophy that reason
became normative for the first time
instead of dreams the entrails of
dismembered birds
or signs in the night sky reason
came to be the arbiter of right and
wrong
it is through reason not from the gods
of the city
tribal mores or the spirits of things
that man can discern what is just from
what is unjust what is good from what is
evil
what is myth from what is reality
he can now discern natural causality
and describe to things their true causes
rather than assigning
magical properties to everything red
dog urine contrary to babylonian belief
is not actually
a causal factor in producing happiness
behaving reasonably or doing what
accords with reason
becomes the standard of moral behavior
and therefore the standard of law to do
what is unreasonable is wrong
as aquinas reflecting aristotle would
later say
the essential character of sin or vice
is its irrationality
however i need another drink of water
aristotle's definition of happiness
set up a major dilemma of which we must
be aware
if we are to understand the significance
of the contribution of christianity
both socrates and aristotle admitted
that the attainment of wisdom was so
difficult
that few if any could achieve it
aristotle said that leisure is a
necessary condition for the
contemplation of the good
as only a few possess leisure this
presents a huge problem
what's more even those with
leisure face nearly insurmountable
obstacles
in obtaining wisdom because human nature
as aristotle said
is in many ways in bondage so that
open quotes the possession of wisdom
might be justly regarded
as beyond human power
unquote this statement seems to be in
tension with aristotle's teaching
that nature ever seeks an end
and always the tendency in each is
towards the same end
and if there is no impediment
how is it then that in all of nature
only man's end seems to be practically
beyond the reach
because of seemingly insurmountable
impediments
if the possession of wisdom is the final
perfection of man
how is it that even in the best regime
the many will never be wise
what about the peasants workers and
slaves
who do not have the possibility of
reaching the height of human attainment
because they have no leisure to pursue
it
what is the purpose or end of their
lives
only to support the leisure of those who
do pursue it
then most of humanity is left out
doomed to frustration
leo strauss observed quote if striving
for knowledge
of the eternal truth is the ultimate end
of man
the man who is merely just or moral
without being a philosopher
appears as a mutilated human being
unquote as aquinas would later say quote
to strive for
any end that cannot be secured is futile
unquote therefore the happiness to which
all men are naturally ordered as their
final perfection
cannot consist in the happiness of only
a very few
that would indeed be futile thus
philosophy
raised a question that it could not
answer
how could man have a nature whose end is
practically unobtainable
the very keenness of this conundrum
made christian revelation
intelligible to the hellenistic world
when it first
received it because it addressed the
problem
that man seemed to be made for something
beyond his reach
against the preceding greek
philosophical background one can come
closer to realizing
the electrifying effect of the opening
of the gospel
of john which was written in greek
the english translation uses word for
logos but it can be rendered just as
well by reason
for our purposes here let us leave the
greek word logos in the quotation
quote in the beginning was the logos
and the logos was with god and the logos
was god
he was in the beginning with god all
things were made through him
unquote revelation
confirmed heraclitus's intuition
that logos makes the universe
comprehensible
because all things were made by and
through logos
lagos is not in it
an intelligible principle or cosmic
force
but a who this is what john announces so
majestically the word incarnate
the startling thing about christianity
is that logos does not simply remain as
the wisdom behind the world
but rather enters into it
logos made flesh
and dwelt among us
what if heraclitus
having speculated on logos
met logos walking through the door
the face of logos made visible is the
transforming experience
of a hellenized christianity or of a
christianized hellenism
the disclosure of christ as logos could
not
be a clearer message that revelation
involves
reason we also know that creation was
made
by way of his divine intellect
god willed or loved creation into being
but it was and is according to his word
at the level of revelation we now know
why the world is rational because god
is reason god speaks to man with equal
force
through his reason as he does through
divine revelation
recall saint paul's famous words to the
romans
quote for since the creation of the
world his invisible attributes are
clearly seen
his everlasting power and also his
divinity unquote
and does not saint peter urge that
christians quote be ready always to
satisfy
everyone that asketh you a reason
of the hope which is in you unquote
early church father clement of
alexandria
insisted on the relevance of reason to
faith quote philosophy
therefore was a preparation paving the
way for him
who is perfected in christ unquote
the mid-century second epistle of
clement also known as the recognitions
spelled out the necessity of reason to
faith
it's worth hearing at length open quotes
do not think that we say that these
things are only to be received by faith
but also that they are to be asserted by
reason
for indeed it is not safe to commit
these things to bear
faith without reason since assuredly
truth cannot be without reason
and therefore he who has received these
things
fortified by reason can never lose them
whereas he who receives them without
proofs
by an ascent to a simple statement of
them can neither keep them safely
nor is certain if they are true
because he who easily believes also
easily
yields but he who has sought reason for
those things which he has believed and
received
as though bound by chains of reason
itself
can never be torn away or separated from
those things
which he hath believed and therefore
according
as anyone is more anxious in demanding a
reason
by so much will he be the firmer in
preserving his faith
excuse me
heaven forbid saint augustine would
later exclaim
quote that we should believe in such a
way
as not to accept or seek reasons
since we could not even believe if we
did not possess
rational souls unquote he also said
quote
believers are also thinkers
in believing they think and in thinking
they believe if faith does not think
it is nothing unquote
now if god is logos
reason and revelation are not at an
impasse
a division of labor defines them the
first vatican council put the
distinction clearly
there is a two-fold order of knowledge
distinct distinct both in origin and an
object in origin because our knowledge
in the one is by natural reason
and in the other by divine faith an
object because besides those things to
which
natural reason can attain there are
proposed to our belief
mysteries hidden in god which unless
revealed
cannot be known the common objective is
the search for in the apprehension of
the
highest things in christianity
father james schall said quote
revelation itself has turned to
philosophy
precisely to explain more fully what is
revealed
unquote christian revelation
confirms reason in its authority
at the same time revelation has a claim
on reason
a philosophy that our priori excludes
the possibility of revelation
is a philosophy that is not true to
itself
on its own terms philosophy
must remain open to revelation
father shaw maintained that revelation
though it discloses
truths beyond the ability of philosophy
to arrive
at unassisted nonetheless addresses
itself to the same reason that
philosophy considers
he said revelation articulates a more
clear and defined end than even the
philosopher could envision by his own
powers
yet the efforts of the efforts of the
philosopher
to envision this end were themselves
needed to understand why
revelational answers were answers to
real questions that did not arise
only from revelation
though he had an inkling of it socrates
did not know that there is a greater
gift than philosophy but without the
philosophical endeavor could man have
come to understand the overwhelming
significance
of this greater gift if the puzzle of
man's purpose had not been posed by
aristotle could man have adequately
appreciated the solution to it
if you haven't asked the question you
won't understand
the answer as mentioned earlier
aristotle saw the need to in so far as
we can
make ourselves immortal and strain every
nerve to live in accordance with the
thing that is best in us
yet he clearly perceived that only a few
with leisure could
even attempt it
what of the vast majority of mankind who
are incapable of the philosophical life
christianity solved this dilemma
posed by aristotle by offering as father
shawn noted to encompass a destiny
that might include all men even
non-philosophers
this conclusion meant that the highest
things were intended for more than just
philosophers indeed
resurrection accomplishes that
final personal happiness which political
theory
initially proposes for man
but for which it had no answer
but aristotle could only vaguely
intimate regarding man's
striving to imitate the divine comes to
startling fruition and christ's offer to
share his divine life
with each person individual man
moves from paltry insignificance to
inestimable worth in the eyes of the
world man is seen as next to nothing in
the brief span of his life
christianity reveals otherwise
for the first time the hidden identity
of
man is disclosed his natural end is
superseded by a supernatural one
in which he partakes of divine life
saint john made the extraordinary
statement
quote it does not yet appear what we
shall be
but we know that when he appears we
shall be
like him for we shall see him as he
is unquote the implication is very clear
that man's destiny is actually to share
in god's divine life
man's end then is outside history
in personal union with a transcendent
and loving god
something man could not dare to have
hoped for
much less imagined until
god revealed himself in christ as
desiring nothing more
than to share his inner life with his
creatures to
impart to them his own divinity
each person could participate in the
divine order of salvation
as an individual not through his
participation
as a citizen of his paulus
or the mediation of a semi-divine ruler
to say that this was a revolutionary
disclosure
is an understatement
however the harmonization of faith and
reason and christianity was disrupted in
the late middle ages
by among others william of arkham
through his exaggerated concern
for god's omnipotence and absolute
freedom of will
and his detestation of what he thought
was the contamination of christianity by
pagan
meaning aristotelian metaphysics
he challenged the tomist teaching that
god's will
proceeds from his divine intellect and
not the other way around
this is the core issue of that time and
our own
aquinas argued that since god is logos
or reason
itself his will follows upon his
intellect
unquote reason rules will
follows the word precedes action
this was not a new teaching in
christianity going back to the third
century hippolytus said of god quote he
thought of it the cosmos
willed it spoke the word and so made it
unquote the primacy of
intellect is clear the intellect
directs the will the will then acts in
accord with reason
occam thought that god's freedom was
compromised by this teaching he flipped
the relationship between intellect and
will
god's will now becomes primary his
intellect subordinate to it is a mere
instrument
this changes everything it is no longer
god's knowledge that constitutes being
it is it's his will
that does so in fact
god knows because he wills will precedes
knowledge
it is the act that produces knowledge
not knowledge that produces the act
will becomes the ontological principle
let's be clear either reason rules
and the will follows or will rules
and reason follows in the latter case
reason simply becomes a tool
for the will to use in however it wishes
to accomplish what it wills
what's more and here is the key key
point
it's impossible intelligibly to
distinguish among
instances of will on the basis of will
alone this was a revolutionary change
with seismic consequences
unless the divine intellect is precedent
proceeding to the divine will
logos cannot be imprinted in creation as
its essential aspect
the more inscrutable the divine will the
more opaque reality
becomes as its product
a spanish scholar fernandez santa maria
wrote quote akam has done away with the
logos
and all that is left in god is will
a will that cannot be bound or limited
by reason inspired actions or
assumptions of man
having expelled from the mind of god the
intelligible world of plato
french philosopher etienne song said
akhem was satisfied that no
intelligibility can be found in any of
god's works
how could there be order in nature when
there is no nature
creation is not imprinted with reason it
cannot reflect what is not there
as a result there is no rational order
invested in the universe upon which one
can rely
only the second to second manifestation
of god's will which he can
change at any moment
for no reason
aquinas said that quote the first cause
of the universe is mind
and that the last end of the universe
must be the good of the mind
that is truth and that in the
contemplation
of truth man finds the principle object
of wisdom
unquote for voluntarists like arkham
the first cause of the universe is will
not mind therefore the last end of the
universe cannot be the good of the mind
the overthrow of the relationship
between reason and faith
is complete man's final end is no longer
rational
without an inherent end by which to
judge the goodness or evil of his
actions
as taking him toward or away from the
perfection of his nature
man is adrift he has no natural good to
guide him
in reality according to nominalist
metaphysics
acts are intrinsically neither good or
bad except insofar as god makes them so
as if in answer to socrates's famous
question
in the euthyphro volunteers like occam
say god does not command certain
behavior because it is good it's good
because he commands
it and he can change
his mind to any his will at any moment
there's not anything objective in the
character of acts themselves
by his command god could turn vices into
virtues
and for instance require us to commit
adultery
or even idolatry
in this radical view of god's
omnipotence he is not only the primary
cause of things but the only cause
there are no secondary causes such as
cause and effect
in the natural world gravity does not
make
objects fall to the earth god does
fire does not burn cotton god does
one must reject the natural order of the
universe
to protect god's omnipotence in this
view
god was not to be limited by any laws of
nature's
essences are an affront to him
this loss of intelligibility
provided some centuries later the
foundation for david humes
find famous is ought distinction
made in the 18th century or what later
came to be called the fact-value
distinction which continues to afflict
us
today
this asserts that there can be no moral
guidance from what exists
or what is to what ought to be
one cannot derive an art from is from an
is
or a value from a fact this is another
consequence of claiming that nature
cannot be normative because there are no
ends in it no tellos to guide things to
become
what they should be in their fullest
according to their essences
in short there's no foundation in
reality
for what ought to be once
one is rid of essences there's not an
ought in sight
we are simply left with what is
machiavelli would take great advantage
of this
it is no surprise that hume concluded
that quote
reason is and ought only to be
the slave of the passions and can never
pretend
to any other office than to serve and
obey them
unquote your reason is a slave
to your passions well it is no great
leap
from the voluntarist exaltation
of the will of god to the voluntarist
exaltation to the will of
man if god is a boundarist we become
voluntarists
by vow interest i mean premised only on
will
not in reason after all if god's
intellect is subordinate
to his will why should man be any
different in subordinating his reason to
his will
as a consequence one gets to make up
one's
own values truth is located in the will
this becomes a very dangerous teaching
when it is politicized
if law is no longer reason what is it
man's law becomes its own standard based
only on the will of the ruler
whether one or many predisposed
to nothing but itself
as berton de juvenal warned quote the
man who finds in god
before all else will in power will be
disposed
to the same view of human government
forty years ago philosopher german
philosopher hans blumenberg remarked
quote when god becomes
nominalism's deus obscurs
the hidden god the god of whom we can
know nothing because he's pure will
the world loses its rational base and
man is left to find whatever meaning and
purpose he can
through his own efforts and that leads
to the modern
project of self-affirmation and
self-assertion
unquote an early manifestation of this
self-assertion came in the form of
marquita condorcet's book
the progress of the human mind which
epitomizes the ambition of the modern
project
quote my work will prove by fact in
reasoning that no bounds have been fixed
to the improvement of the human
faculties
that the perfectibility of man is truly
limitless unquote
the phrase the limitless perfectability
of man
captures the metaphysical incoherence of
modernity
limitless perfectibility is an oxymoron
anything limitless is by definition
incapable of perfection
as we have seen the perfection of
something is the fulfillment of its
nature
if perfectability is without limits as
kondra say says
it means that it loses its direction
because nature is precisely about limits
and if no direction exists regression
is indistinguishable from progression
alexis de tocqueville wrote that men of
the revolution the french revolution
quote had a robust faith in man's
perfectability and power
they had no doubt that they were
appointed to transform the human race
these sentiments
and passions had become a sort of new
religion unquote the object of faith in
this new religion
changes from god to humanity
from a god-centered perspective to one
of man's
self-sufficiency or rather his
self-creation
but never to man as he is
only to man as he could be or must
become
in the common communist version
homo sapiens becomes
homo sovieticus under the nazi ideology
man as he is must be purged of his
racial impurities
to reign as ubermensch the over man
or the beyond man who creates and
imposes his own values
all of this testifies to the truth of
g.k chesterton's quip
here paraphrased that the man who ceases
to believe in god does not believe in
nothing
rather he will believe in anything
chesterton also said quote just as one
generation
could prevent the very existence of the
next generation
by all entering a monastery or jumping
into the sea
so one set of thinkers can in some
degree prevent
further thinking by teaching the next
generation
that there's no validity in any human
thought
unquote we seem now to have reached that
point of ignorance
because we have had more than one set of
thinkers espousing this teaching
for many and for more than one
generation
if we don't know what we are or who we
are can we we can self-identify as
anything
this self-identification is not the
result of knowing oneself but of willing
oneself
if what one wills is the principle
constituent of reality
there's no standard by which one act of
the will can be
differentiated from any other act of the
will thus
i have no right to judge your values and
you cannot judge mine
the common good is the casualty
therefore
a man can self-identify as a woman
however why can't i self-identify as
someone who finds that utterly absurd
if i don't want to be canceled we are
living in a period of moral and cultural
self asphyxiation it will end us
if we don't return to reality soon
let's transpose the self-identity talked
to an earlier period to illustrate this
absurdity
the nazis who believed in the primacy of
will
self-identified as racist haters of jews
and slavs
whom they proceeded to slaughter and
enslave
did opposition to this arise because the
opponent
simply self-identified as anti-nazis
no it arose among those who held that
all men are created equal is a universal
truth
and that therefore what the nazis were
doing was objectively evil and must be
stopped
the uncle after whom i was named
gave his life in order to stop it he did
not make that self
that sacrifice so that people could
self-identify
but so that the universal truth that is
the true basis of freedom would be
upheld
well what goes first faith or reason
that's very much a chicken and egg kind
of question
it seems to me that they both stand or
fall together
without faith reason has shown itself
capable of
reasoning itself out of existence
fulton sheen once described
an intellectual as someone who's been
educated beyond his intelligence
reason without faith ultimately ends in
nihilism
without reason faith becomes something
like sunni islam
today there is not a faith reason fight
there is a faith reason flight
our current condition illustrates that a
society will decline to the extent that
it loses
faith and that the loss of reason is
concurrent with it
in democracy in america alexis de
tocqueville observed quote
anglo-american
civilization is the result of two
distinct
elements which in other places have been
in frequent
disagreement but which the americans
have succeeded in incorporating to some
extent
one with the other and combining
admirably
i allude to the spirit of religion and
the spirit of liberty
unquote
can it be any surprise that as our
spirit
of religion has declined so too has our
spirit of liberty
so we come full circle if at times by a
circuitous route
to the question of the relationship of
faith and reason
if you're told that your faith excludes
your reason
ask how it knows that if you're told
your reason excludes your faith
ask how it could know that
you need your reason to understand your
faith more fully
and you need your faith to open your
reason to whatever is otherwise beyond
it
always keep before yourself your
ultimate destination
seek the truth recognize
and know it live by it
abide in it that is why we are here
this is our purpose
god bless hillsdale college
thank you mr riley mr riley has agreed
to sign copies of his book
america on trial a defense of the
founding
on the second floor of the sural lobby
following this session
we do have time for some q a if you have
a question please make your way to one
of the microphones in the side aisles
um you mentioned the fate fact value
split which is something we discussed
actually quite a bit in the western
theological tradition
core class and then right at the end to
live and abide
by our faith um do you have any
suggestions on how
to open up that conversation with people
who are unwilling to listen and how to
bring
that idea back into our society
well i mean this sounds like a perverse
comment but
you know thank heavens for the nazis i
mean you you can always say to them
ought we to have opposed the nazis ought
we to have
uh is is that a fact or is that a value
or how would you know you ought
to do that there must be some moral
foundation for that
and the other thing is you know i find
this very curious
no one goes to
an eye doctor
and receives a diagnosis and then
says to the doctor oh well that's what
you think
or if it's something serious maybe they
get a second opinion but they'd never
say well
that's just you know i i
i i don't think that that's just your
opinion no why why not
well because the ophthalmologist or the
optometrist knows what the eye of the
eye is for
what's it for well to see
and if it's not seeing it's suffering
from a corruption an imperfection
and from his studies he would know
where in that imperfection lies it may
be able to correct it
that's why you go to him the only reason
he knows that is because he knows the
purpose of an eye
what an i ought to be
and we can march through the human body
and make the same
observations except when you
get below the waist people say well what
could that possibly be for
well let's let's just experiment and
find no no we know just as much about
that as
the natural moral law rules that just as
much as it does everything else
so it as people remonstrate with you
that they're saying you ought not to
well that's an
that's an art you know what it where did
they get it
probably from an is somewhere they just
don't understand that
that the fact value distinction is
itself
a corruption of reason
i'm sure that's going to win you a lot
of friends just take them right through
that
i'm sorry for going on so long but
actually i cut this talk
it would have been it would have been in
more pain
sir hi thanks for being here my question
was about
discerning what the ultimate end of
something is you
spoke well from aristotle that you
determine what's good based off of
something's end and to what degree it
reaches that end into what degree it
corrupts before it gets to that end it
seems to me that many reasonable people
disagree about the end of man
and with respect to many social
issues also with respect to political
things
reasonable people disagree about what
the purpose of man is and
what a good life looks like so
what does what does that bring us to and
how do we resolve those
reasonable disagreements and what does
faith have to say
in those disagreements well i think what
you have what you encounter today more
often than not
in such disagreements is you're talking
to someone who doesn't think man has any
purpose at all
and therefore it's just you know he says
she says
or that's your opinion or you don't have
the right to judge me and i don't have
there's no basis for judgment
whereas they would admit that those ends
exist
every time they go to a doctor and yet
all of a sudden they don't exist when it
comes to a moral issue
which could be corrupting their soul and
so
it do you think anyone would contest
at the end of man is happiness
is that well they say it's unhappiness
now what what you can
i don't think you'd find many people who
who wouldn't say that
at the end of our nature is to be happy
they might say we don't have a nature
just as people say that the universe is
accidental right
how could anything have a purpose if all
of this happened
by accident which is the alternative is
if there is no logos then everything is
accidental
and then of course there are no ends
there are just accidents
um now if you can establish that that
that end exists
like happiness obtainable through the
life of virtue
there can be then quite legitimate and
very
interesting arguments about the means to
reach that end
and often those discussions are are sort
of on prudential matters
how best to reach these the acknowledged
end of that
happiness which is the ultimate
perfection of our nature
the other thing you know you find out is
that
the there's something wrong with death
no one wants well very few people really
want to die
and we rebel at the thought of dying
we rebel at the thought of not existing
i remember when my kids were very young
one of them i told them where was i when
that picture you know
was taken of the other kids well matthew
you didn't exist yet
that i had to be well no actually you
didn't you
you came into being so
once you have an experience of death in
a family or loved one there's an
enormous
uh grievance there you know there's
something wrong
with death that happiness must
also involve immortality and that of
course is what
aristotle argues i mean socrates argues
for
mainly from justice that we have to have
immortal souls in order for perfect
justice to be achieved in
you know in in the afterlife but it also
obtains to the end of happiness so there
are all kinds of human experience that
scream out
for this kind of treatment no i guess
that didn't
it's a tough question it's a really good
question thank you for it
so i'm happy to talk to anybody upstairs
for the book signing if you buy one i
thank you
my children thank you
maybe i can even get larry yarn to thank
you that would be one
so thank you very much
you